this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armies Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this week's episode Jonathan is taking a
look at more of the weapons from Call of
Duty Warzone and naturally we had to
show him a few cursed guns too
the Burger Town classic vaguely horrific
with the sort of meat texture
oh that's horrible
truly horrible
if there are any other games guns and
mechanics that you guys want to see
Jonathan break down let us know in the
comment section below and if you'd like
to help out the Royal armories Museum
and continue to support Jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right let's take a look at
the weapons of Call of Duty warzone
foreign
-94 here is one we've been very
fortunate to acquire a fully intact
example here suffice to say it's
extremely complicated it's a gun inside
a gun so how how is Call of Duty done
well not great but then it's deliberate
so this is a one of the legally
different designs I don't particularly
know why that's done but it has been
made X percent different from the real
thing so just off the top of my head
just the profile of the receiver is
different not not wildly so there's no
separate handguard section at the front
here with that seam that they put in
there that's been that's invented the
notably the sights are completely
different so the an has this very
distinctive wheel shaped rear sight that
you turn you get your aperture by
turning to the next
blade on this one it's a conventional
rear aperture that just sits on top the
front side is a fully shrouded protected
arrangement with this sort of
trapezoidal or hexagonal shape on this
it's an open top I don't really know why
they've called it there 94 when they
could have called it something else but
probably because people aren't as nerdy
as me and they won't notice or care
about the differences and so the name
recognition still matters the only
change that really matters from a
functional point of view I would suggest
is this muzzle device because to the
best of my knowledge this distinctive
twin chamber sort of cyclone muzzle
device is actually essential to getting
sufficient back pressure for this gun
inside a gun to actually function this
this default kind works like a Bulgarian
muzzle device AK star muzzle device
wouldn't necessarily allow the gun to
operate correctly
foreign
this is an Italian design but it's uh
part of Italy that was basically a
puppet state of Germany in the Second
World War I don't think that's
particularly relevant except for sort of
context it's clearly not a German or
German inspired design I don't think
although I suppose it's not necessarily
characteristically Italian either it's a
bit of an oddball it is it's not a ball
pup but it is a compact design so with
the magazine forming the pistol grip you
are abbreviating the length of the
weapon got something to show you um it's
not the OG 43 it's the OG 44 so this was
the follow-up which is much more
conventional this version is not in Call
of Duty but it's the closest thing we
have and it's relatively rare in its own
right it also allows me to illustrate
what I mean by it being shorter so if I
put the magazine back in this works
conventionally so this has a pistol grip
here by moving the trigger guard to this
position I'm making the whole thing
substantially shorter several inches
shorter so why they went sort of
backwards to a longer design I'm not
quite sure it functions I believe pretty
similarly the cocking handle is on the
top it is open bolts as the gun in the
game is depicted as being however I'm
not seeing the bolt forward when the
player runs out of ammunition which is
what we'd expect would expect the bolt
to be in that condition and then
re-cooked ready for firing and every
subsequent shot so I'm not sure that's
been quite correctly modeled but we
don't have one of these so maybe it's a
quirk
oh that's horrible
truly horrible
so the base gun here is a real design uh
frustratingly Call of Duty has given it
a fictional name of Cooper rifle it's
actually the Thompson Hyde model 1944
which is effectively a stamped sheet
metal version of a Tommy Gun in 30
carbine so the M1 carbine cartridge it's
experimental didn't go anywhere almost a
surprise that it didn't really you could
you could absolutely see the um America
in the 1950s using this
as their replacement for the for the
Thompson but it didn't happen it's a
very rare prototype we haven't got one
we have the Hyde rifle but not the
Thompson hide and then I've been
presented with as is tradition a truly
horrific modified version with bodged
hand guards from something I'm not I
can't even recognize what those are
we've got a sort of Outrigger foregrip
thing sprouting out of the magazine well
a large coffin shaped magazine weird
grip Optical sight and a comedy charm
I've seen worse but uh it's still not
great
thank you
right the ever popular Accuracy
International this is I've I think meant
to be it has styling cues from the later
accuracy Internationals but I think it's
meant to be the PM or Precision Marksman
which you will perhaps know better as
the British l96a1 now the this has as I
mentioned it has some of the the stock
is a bit closer to the more modern
design with the plastic insert here for
the for the hand grip and it has a
muzzle brake on it or at least this
version does and a picatinny rail when
the l96 was invented that standardized
Picatinny slash NATO rail or even um
even the Weaver equivalent was not
um not available so this has a standard
sort of dovetail
site so you need a specific mount for it
this was designed as a sniper rifle from
the ground up and it was very good and
only replaced by a bigger Accuracy
International rifle the l115 which is
still in service and that's in 338 lap
of a magnum this is in 762 which I think
is what the uh the Cod rifle is supposed
to be in five round magazine and the
reason I've chosen this one is that we
actually fired this for filming of the
new series of Loadout which is coming
soon on this very channel so look out
for that
foreign
this is a sort of extremely cursed P90
both in its redesign it's inexplicable
maybe anime inspired redesign and then
of course somebody has decorated it so
it still has the P90 cocking handles the
version of the magazine catch the
magazine is weird I don't like that sort
of reverse Outrigger sight Mount I think
there's a reason why the P90 has the
bridge over the top of the receiver to
stabilize the sights uh the whole thing
just looks like a toy
foreign
just generic neon pink Mist when we hit
the enemy almost like some sort of
paintball effect I think the Tracer fire
as well I mean you don't get Tracer fire
out of firearms unless you put Tracer
ammunition in them but regardless for
this gun it's pink it's unspeakable
really
enemy precision air strike stay alert
enemy Precision this is a second World
War weapon the ptrs-41 as in 1941.
semi-automatic 14.5 by 114 millimeters
that's a very long very powerful round
and they are still around and they're
still useful because they will penetrate
a hard cover vehicles and the Call of
Duty rendition is pretty good in terms
of how it looks I would have grabbed
ours to show you but I physically
couldn't do it now the main thing I I
learned from that other than I should
never be a soldier is there is no way in
heck that even a very strong
well-trained individual can carry that
around and run and Gun with it
absolutely no way the balance the weight
of this thing the length of this thing
the version in in the game is definitely
shorter by about a foot or more than the
real thing just not plausible and it's
not designed for that it's essentially a
cruise-served weapon or at least a
two-man team and you have to post up
with it in a hardpoint or on the ground
at least and try to engage your vehicles
or your aircraft on the ground or
whatever it is you're trying to attack
you absolutely cannot use it in the way
that the game depicts
now this is a bit of a surprise I wasn't
aware that this had been introduced and
it's sort of one of these this is the
Italian Broder PG 1935
self-loading rifle are really important
and very rare Museum firearm here but
you'll notice that it is as well as
being Italian the one in the game is the
Costa Rican version this uses the
Carcano it's in six five Carcano on
block clip system just like the the bolt
action rifles did so it doesn't have the
detachable magazine that would really
cramp your style in a Call of Duty game
nor does it have the four round burst
automatic feature which we saw
represented there so you've got a I
don't know if it had a 24 round magazine
I'd have to look that up um but it you
know multiples of four I suppose that
would make sense and you see that four
rounds are expended every time you fire
the weapon in game the basic design is
the same though the gun in the game is
different in a lot of details I have to
go and check some sources to see if
they've deliberately departed from the
design as they sometimes do but the big
blocky receiver is there the sliding
dust cover on the top and one of the
major features of this that they have
correctly modeled very complicated
looking bolt in here is it's open bolt
like a lot of submachine guns you fire
it from an open bolt and this one is
semi-automatic only intriguingly it also
has the name antonucci carved into the
wooden stock maybe that's not a
soldier's name you need to look into
this but as far as I knew they were not
General issues so I need to do a bit of
research on that
quite a nice looking gun there I think
with the mixture of the wooden furniture
and the sort of blackened steel looks
like a G3 and it's the sort of dally of
the G3 it's the set me they're a weird
sort of alternate universe HMK range of
products nowhere near as varied or
successful as hacker and craft but
really quite similar because same
original designer here it's a semi
semi-fictionalized version but it's
pretty close to the real thing even the
model number is is a close reference so
c58 refers to set me at 58 the first two
model model 58. so 1958 is when it's
finalized I think this is supposed to be
the model C which is a 70s incremental
Improvement on the original by which
time the G3 is already in existence over
in Germany so that means we get the
standard or version of the standard h k
reload with the the famous slap but
they've gone for the Judo chop version
which is doable on those rifles because
they have bigger surface area to hit
than the little plastic half moon shape
nubbing on the MP5 which if you chop it
with the edge of your hand is likely to
hurt
I'm struggling to wrap my head around
why there is a directed energy weapon in
a call any Call of Duty game because
it's right to my best of my knowledge we
never got far enough into the future for
such a thing to be remotely plausible
especially this one which is at this
point has been fitted with the ludicrous
pseudo World War II Optical site I mean
why they'd be designing future guns to
to take a fictional second world war Red
Dot sight I don't know overall design it
looks pretty cool it looks like maybe
something from something wet a workshop
might come up with and that's a
compliment by the way it's just
horrifically out of place in any of the
Call of Duty games that are currently in
existence to my knowledge the the the
charger constant beam phase Star Trek
phaser style effect if I'm going to have
a laser gun I do quite like that idea
reminds me of half life better yeah why
is it in Call of Duty guys
yes
yeah uh
the Burger Town classic
yeah what can I say
not much
vaguely horrific with the sort of meat
texture
so this is this is sort of the essay VZ
25. this is the Czechoslovakian Cold War
era submachine gun the 25 is in 9 by 19
and it has the 25 that is has this pull
and fold
and then press in the latch on the butt
plate section to latch it into place and
let it go so you can use that as a fork
grip the Call of Duty version is quite
different the front half is pretty close
the cocking handle is different it's a
completely different shape open bolt
operation it's got that right so then
the back half the stock is attached
almost like a like a well rod grip with
tabs and two screws not with this all
enveloping rear sight section here which
is a more robust setup and then this
rear sight that I that I don't like is
replaced by a standard aperture rear
sight with protectors on it so they've
changed up the back end of the gun the
proportions look different too other
details are changed I'm going to sound
like a broken record but if you're
trying to replicate an historical
firearm replicate it
next up is a drunken Firearms designers
take on the French Famas assault rifle
with the rail with the chop down upper
receiver with the rail it's more like
the valerise the modernized Famas but it
definitely has the air of something
they've nailed the Cold War sheet metal
look but of course the farm ass is not
all sheet metal it has substantial
polymer in it I can't quite tell if
they're trying to replicate that or not
suffice to say it doesn't if you were to
map this over a Famas it isn't really
much of a match it's highly stylized it
has the folding built-in bipod down the
side of the receiver it has an
impression of the grenade launching ring
on the barrel which is what those
grooves and the ring that slides up and
down them is the flash hider is
comically large not sure why that's so
big then the proportions of the receiver
as I say do not really match the Famas
very well at all I guess that's why they
called it the far and not the famous
it's the FN SCAR Special Operations
forces combat assault rifle or
abbreviations along those lines there's
at least one other yeah not far off not
a bad effort once again it has been
changed up even things like how many
screws there are in the side the fact
that the upper receiver looks like it's
made out of the same material as the
butt stock and the pistol grip I.E
polymer when in fact it's machined
aluminum or aluminum if you prefer the
lower receiver on in the on the game
version has the reinforcing rib down the
side which is an arm an AR feature not
on the scar notice it's not there the
magazine is pretty bang on although even
then they've changed the shape of the
rubber bumper why why change it don't
know but the overall impression is
pretty close the more you look the more
difference you see this is this is
becoming a theme with Call of Duty
weapons so three vents either side at
the front on the real thing one big slot
on the fictional version gas blocks not
a million miles away but then the barrel
has the step cut in it that the M4 has
and there's no need for that because the
grenade launcher for this attaches to
the picatinny rail on the bottom and
that Notch is specifically for the
grenade launcher because it was designed
to fit around an M16 A1 Barrel not an
m16a2 Barrel which is why the M4 has to
have the notch because the m16a2
had an m16a1 profile Barrel under the
handguard so you took the handguards off
your mounted your grenade launcher with
the Shroud around it job done the scar
doesn't need a barrel of that profile
foreign
ly pleased to see this because I really
love the design and it's a gun we don't
have this is the demontier patent knife
revolver anyway I love it because the
barrel and the blade are forged together
it's the blade is forged from the barrel
so it really some of them are really
beautiful this one arguable it's a
little bit decorated but nice if weird
thing to have in a game and then when we
we open it up we you know to break
action design which I don't think they
actually were there might be one out
there but they're typically a solid
frame gate loading design so we've we've
seen it Chuck out all its cases through
the side of its solid cylinder and then
it breaks open and all the same cases
come flying out so it's very clearly
just an oversight they've left in
they've based it on the model of
something else that does eject empty
cases and they've just left that
animation in
got an unusual one very unusual to be
running around with that's that's the
major criticism You Can level at this
this is not a gun that you would like to
be running around with this is the
Marlin model
1917. here it's been adapted a bit like
I suppose a Vicar's gas operated gun as
a sort of infantry gun but you can see
from the big mounting lugs on the
receiver there that is that's not what
it's designed for so it's actually quite
nice to see something in a game that I
haven't seen before and I think they've
actually modeled it well I haven't been
able to get hold of one to compare the
ballooned steel looks really good with
wear and damage to it but also still the
shine at this time they're still
lovingly finishing things with with a
lovely shiny blue finish very soon into
the second world war that goes out the
window and everyone is kind of
phosphating or painting things
[Applause]
foreign
of another Call of Duty Warzone video
and we've survived mostly intact a few
Horrors in there very much appreciate
you watching as always please do come
and visit one of our three museums here
in the UK we do have our own YouTube
channel which we've been uh shamelessly
borrowing you lovely people for to come
and come and watch please do carry on
doing that we also have several social
social media Outlets that you may wish
to engage with but otherwise we will see
you again next week thanks again for
watching
foreign
[Music]